Thank you very much, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome!
Thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you for watching.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, this is big.
Last night,
"Time" magazine announced
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
as 2020's Person of the Year.
Yeah.
After the announcement,
Trump called Rudy Giuliani
and was like,
"Forget the election.
We're suing 'Time' magazine."
Apparently,
"Time" magazine was like,
"There's so many worthy people,
but who would annoy Trump
the most?"
I got to be honest,
I thought it was going to be
frontline healthcare workers,
especially since
doctor's offices
is the only place you still find
a copy of "Time" magazine.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
They picked Biden and Harris
over Trump.
Even worse, the original cover
was the two of them
going down a ramp.
That's -- Oh.
"I had very slippery shoes on.
And I couldn't do it.
It was very slippery."
That's right. Trump and his
staff were pretty annoyed
that he wasn't named
"Time's" Person of the Year,
but they managed grabbed a
couple of other magazine covers.
Let me show you what I mean.
Trump was honored by a magazine
which covers two of his
favorite things, food and whine.
[ Laughter ]
Michael Flynn received the honor
from "Better Homes & Pardons."
Steve Mnuchin
was honored by "Mnewsweek."
[ Laughter ]
Wilbur Ross was featured
on the cover of...
"One Hundred Seventeen."
That's...
Mike Pence was given the honor
from something called
"This is a Magazine."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, Rudy Giuliani
was featured in
"Field & Streaming."
Yeah, there you go, everybody.
Congrats.
Congrats to you guys
on those covers.
And this is just wild.
It just came out
that Trump's chief of staff
told the head of the FDA
to approve
the Pfizer vaccine today
or resign.
Trump's like,
"We need this vaccine today
for a virus
I've ignored since March.
We need it today!"
[ Applause ]
I think we let the FDA
have their moment.
I mean, 80% of their job is just
putting out lettuce recalls.
Give them a little something.
I got to say, though,
in Trump's defense,
if the FDA is allowing
Pizza Hut's triple-decker box,
then this should not
be a problem.
Meanwhile, I saw that Walmart
is preparing to administer
COVID vaccines at its stores.
[ Applause ]
That's the good news.
The bad news is they're
gonna be given to you
by a Walmart greeter.
"Hold still.
Oh, here comes
the pointy airplane.
Oh, I'm going down.
I'm going down.
Come down with me.
There's no way I'm getting up.
You've got to come down here
to get the shot."
Reminds me of a few years ago
when my uncle
had a heart valve replaced
at K-Mart.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, Walmart's
a great place to give vaccines
'cause no one's
wearing sleeves anyway.
Here's some big
entertainment news.
[ Laughter ]
Here's some big
entertainment news.
Disney just held
their annual Investor Day
where they announced
a bunch of new projects.
Check this out.
-Disney announces a slew
of new original programming.
Ten new "Star Wars" projects
are on the way.
New Marvel projects
Plus, spinoffs, reboots, sequels
for some Disney favorites.
Tom Hanks in a live-action
"Pinocchio."
And a Buzz Lightyear
origin story.
-Yeah, Disney is going to
release 50 new titles
from Marvel, "Star Wars,"
and Pixar.
Families in quarantine
heard it and were like,
"Where the hell was this
ten months ago?! Come on!"
When the news broke,
Netflix was like,
"Well, there goes our show
about backgammon."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Disney's releasing
ten new "Star Wars" series.
Everything from "Star Wars"
is getting a spinoff.
There's even a show
about the cantina
trying to set up outdoor dining.
That seems...
[ Laughter ]
This is very exciting.
Disney also announced
that Harrison Ford will star
in a fifth and final
"Indiana Jones" movie.
That's right.
It's a two-hour adventure
of him trying to remember
where he left his hat.
He's like, "I switched it
with the idol? Did I...
Where did I --
Oh, I'm wearing it."
[ Laughter ]
At his age, the only
giant boulder attacking him
is a kidney stone.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Well, hey --
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, Taylor Swift
just released another new album
called "Evermore,"
and her fans are going crazy.
[ Applause ]
That is two albums
and a documentary
in the past five months.
She is on fire right n--
-[ Notification chimes ]
-I just got a notification.
Taylor Swift just released
a third album.
It's called "Sycamore."
Wow. That's unbelievable.
Anyway, she --
-[ Notification chimes ]
-Wow. She released
a fourth album.
It's called "Sophomore."
How does she have
the time for this?
Well, anyway, she --
-[ Notification chimes ]
-Her fifth album
is called "Furthermore."
It just dropped.
Well, she can't keep this up.
I mean, can she? I mean, she --
[ Clock ticking ]
[ Notification chimes ]
Her 17th album
is called "Pottermore."
It's a whole album
about Harry Potter.
[ Clock ticking ]
[ Notification chimes ]
This is her 36th album.
It's called "Julianne Moore."
[ Clock ticking ]
[ Notification chimes ]
Huh. Wait.
Paramore just released an album
called "Taylor Swift."
Well, it came full circle.
Well, let's move on.
Let's move on.
Congratulations, Paramore.
And finally, a new survey
found that this year
one in five Americans
have gotten hurt
putting up their Christmas tree.
How annoying is that
for overrun hospitals?
It's like, "Make room.
This dummy fell
on his Christmas tree."
One patient was like,
"Is it bad?"
And the doctor was like,
"Well, I'm a proctologist,
so you tell me."
We have exactly six shows left
before we go on Christmas break.
Is that it? Six shows left?
Wow. It's happening so fast.
Which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go!
-♪ 12 days
of Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Six days left ♪
-That is right!
Every show between now
and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a bewitching Christmas sweater.
[ Laughs ]
From the Countdown to Christmas
cabinet, it's bewitching.
Now, since there are
six shows left,
let's open door number 6.
[ Drumroll ]
Yes. Let's see it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ] Wow.
All right. Oh, my goodness.
I think I already have that one.
That is gorgeous.
Can we see?
Is there a back to it?
-That's a cape.
-Yeah, it's kind of caped.
-Capey.
-Yeah, it's very capey,
that one.
-Yeah.
-I love it.
I think it's gorgeous.
I actually --
I would totally, uh --
I would totally give that away.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see who is going home with
tonight's Christmas sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
Making sure you know
it's random.
136! Where you are at?
Oh, come on down!
♪♪
Ah. Oh, my goodness.
Look at that. Ohh!
Thank you so much
for being here.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-Zady, and I'm from here
in New York.
-Hey. Zady from New York.
Come on.
Zady, thank you for being here,
first of all. I appreciate it.
Do you have anything like this?
-No, this is the first one
of these that I get.
-Wow.
-I'm excited.
-Yeah, I think
it might be the only one.
Would you mind trying it on?
-Yes.
-Zady is going to try it on,
everybody.
Roots, can I get
some trying-on music?
♪♪
Zady, this is going to delight
not only you but others,
if you Zoom to call anyone.
It's very easy to put it on.
Zady, it's almost perfect
like that.
But don't rush.
Zady, that's --
[ Laughter ]
It's -- Oh, oh, oh!
Oh! Ohh! Wow!
Oh, we did it! Yes!
That is what I'm talking about!
Zady! Take a spin!
Ohh! Is that not
the most beautiful thing
you've ever seen?
Thank you so much to
our lucky audience member.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with "Thank You Notes,"
everybody.
♪♪